a report out this morning shows
thousands of children are injured or
killed by furniture that tips over and
the numbers are growing Consumer Reports
tested 24 different dresser models and
is calling for a mandatory safety
standard the Consumer Product Safety
Commission says tip over injuries for
children under 6 rose by 33 percent from
2015 to 2016 Anna Werner shows us why
Consumer Reports believes the industry
standard is inadequate and I can't watch
those with kids right exactly it's hard
to watch
and there are voluntary standards for
dressers but advocates wanted to know
why were so many kids still being
injured or killed now they and parents
who have lost children say the answer is
the voluntary standards that currently
exist aren't enough just in this like
little sliver of time our lives had
changed forever
for Janet McGee that change came on a
Sunday afternoon in 2016 as she checked
to see if her 22 month old son Ted had
woken up from his afternoon nap I opened
the door in right in front of me his
dresser I saw on the floor it had fallen
forward in that split second I knew he
was under there the toddler was buried
under the dresser drawers
he had suffocated his face was purple
his eyes were half open it was a
horrible vision that unfortunately I'm
still haunted by every single day the
accidents can happen like this one seen
in a home monitoring video last year as
two toddlers climbed onto a dresser
tipping it over one boy was trapped for
nearly two minutes but both escaped
uninjured many kids aren't so lucky
government data shows from 2014 to 2016
more than 15,000 children under 18 were
injured in tip overs from 2000 to 2016
more than 150 children died from tip
overs of dressers bureaus or with a TV
on top so Consumer Reports conducted tip
over testing on 24 different dressers
subjecting each to progressively tougher
tests some more stringent than the
current voluntary standard
the result the group says the voluntary
standard is inadequate because it still
leaves too many children at risk across
the board for parents who are trying to
figure out which dressers are safer than
others how easy is that it's extremely
difficult you cannot judge a dresser
whether it's going to be tippy or not
just by looking at it Consumer Reports
is now calling for a mandatory standard
to protect children in a statement the
American Home Furnishings Alliance told
CBS this morning
it is not opposed to mandatory product
safety standards but said they cannot be
easily revised or updated once passed
Consumer Reports says by the numbers
however most dressers actually passed
their toughest test some of them are
already doing a fantastic job so what
you're saying is look they all can do
that it is possible it is achievable and
it doesn't require extra cost you can
make dressers that are very stable at
all price points at all shapes all sizes
all Heights all weights if you want to
see the results for specific
manufacturers you can check consumer
reports see also how those manufacturers
responded but it's in the meantime if
you're a parent of young children the
answer is right now anchor furniture and
not just dressers anything you think
might tip over anchors cost they say
about five dollars you can go to cbs.com
we've linked to the Consumer Reports
report which has detailed information on
all these manufacturers it sounds so
easy to do that happened to me when
favorite daughter Kirby was - I'm hoping
she doesn't remember it she pulled the
dirt the bottom out stood on it I had
left the room that I thought for a
second and I came to heard this big
crash and it was on top of her Wow I
thought does the cost of the dresser
matter this was not a very well-made
dresser I believe yeah it's a cross
matter I'm glad she was okay and that's
the thing no it doesn't Gail what they
found is that you can buy a dresser at a
higher price a lower price and you are
not going to know there's no way to know
yes that dresser won't fall over or no
it won't just heartbreaking on the Anker
heartbreaking to hear from Janet - who
did baby proof her Yeah right she's
trying to get the word out Anna thank
you